- [Narrator] A Kodak moment was
once synonymous with photos.
- [Narrator] The moments
of your life are priceless.
Are you saving them on the right film?
Kodak Gold.
- [Narrator] At its peak,
Eastman Kodak was the early
20th century equivalent
of Google or Apple,
once possessing a near
monopoly in the film business.
But the company's days at
the top are now a memory.
Since the digital revolution unspooled
the company's dominant position,
itt's released products
to try and keep up,
some a far cry from cameras and film,
and recently an announcement
to produce drug ingredients
sent it's stock price surging
and embroiled the company
in a controversy that has
thrust it back in the limelight,
which has raised questions
amongst consumers and investors alike.
Can the company create
another Kodak moment?
George Eastman got into the
photography business in 1880
and he pledged to make taking photos
as convenient as the pencil.
You can see that notion
in an early slogan,
"you press the button, we do the rest".
In 1884 he patented a way of
packaging film in a roll form
and four years later introduced
the first Kodak camera.
Then in 1889, Eastman began selling
the first commercial
transparent roll film,
which made it possible for Thomas Edison
to develop the motion picture camera.
- So it's a highly profitable business
and you don't have a
whole lot of competitors.
That's basically the
business model right there.
- [Narrator] The company
innovated photographic solutions
for consumers and businesses alike.
For example, the Rekodak
was a 1920s camera
that allowed banks to photograph
checks to prevent fraud.
George Eastman died in 1932,
but his namesake company
stayed focused on his vision
of turning photography
and then film into a
pastime for ordinary people.
- They had this one product
that had a high level
of profit margin that allowed them
to do a lots of other things.
They would get into lens manufacturing.
They would get into the copier business.
I mean, they had lots
of different businesses,
but the core of it really was
the profit margin from film.
- [Narrator] Kodak's dominance continued
through World War II, then
competition began to emerge.
Polaroid released in 1948 a
new camera that turned out
a finished picture one minute
after the shutter snapped,
but Kodak remained in the
eyes of some, a monopoly
and faced multiple antitrust
cases from the US government.
Still the company continued
introducing new products
like simpler, more
affordable movie cameras.
- Let me show you how
easy Kodak has made it
for you and me with a Kodak
Instamatic movie camera.
- [Narrator] And with an
eye towards maintaining
it's position well into the future,
the company in 1978 patented
the first digital camera,
which saved images onto a cassette tape,
but it was slow on commercializing
digital camera technology
because it feared it would
cannibalize its film business.
- Digital photography was
not their prime business.
Digital photography was largely funded by
the profits made by film.
- [Narrator] By 1988,
Kodak had become a mammoth
international company that employed
more than 145,000 people.
That year it had its
highest earnings ever.
The company viewed rival
Fuji as its biggest threat.
The Japanese company was
going after Kodak loyalists
with promotions and advertising.
By 1989, Fuji had captured
11% of the US market.
For Kodak the days of double digit growth
in its film business were over.
In 1993 the film giant brought
in a CEO from the outside
to turn things around.
George Fisher was credited
with Motorola's resurgence
and when he got to Kodak,
Fisher fought what he viewed
as Fuji's unfair advantage
in the Japanese market.
- What we face is in
fact a highly controlled
distribution system that
denies Kodak full access
to Japan's consumer film and paper market.
- [Narrator] The World Trade
Organization ultimately
rejected US claims of
Japanese protectionism
in photographic film.
Meanwhile, Fisher pursued another priority
pushing the company into the digital era.
- But it wasn't a profitable
is to say probably
they didn't make money
on any of these products.
- [Narrator] In 1997,
digital imaging could
become a loss leader for the company.
That year Kodak was on track to lose
an estimated $400 million and
in traditional film products,
Fuji was continuing to gain market share.
That fall Kodak slashed 10,000 jobs.
At the turn of the millennium
a new CEO entered the scene
and introduced a slew of new products.
Some of them actually took.
It entered the inkjet and
digital printer markets
competing head on with Hewlett
Packard, Canon and Epson.
- So they said, all right,
prints are the way to go.
So we'll sell a home printer
for a reasonable money,
but unfortunately the
one thing that happened
is with this business is it
just never really took off
because people just don't make
that many photographic prints anymore.
- [Narrator] People stopped
printing photos in part
because this happened.
- Every once in a while, a
revolutionary product comes along
that changes everything.
- [Narrator] In 2007,
Apple's always with you cam
the iPhone ushered in a
photographic revolution.
- On the back, the biggest thing of note
is we got a two megapixel
camera built right in.
- [Narrator] Between 2008 and
2011 Kodak's digital camera
sales began to decline year after year.
To survive it sold off
some of its businesses
and its patent portfolio.
- If you look at sales of
point and shoot cameras,
whether it's film cameras
or digital cameras,
they're basically almost gone.
- [Narrator] In 2012, the company filed
for bankruptcy protection
and got out of the
digital camera business.
For a new generation iPhone
and Instagram supplanted Kodak
as the brand synonymous with photography.
Kodak emerged from bankruptcy
about a year later with a new CEO.
- The Kodak brand is probably
one of the best known brand
names in the world.
So part of what they ended
up doing was to license
that word, their name.
You name it, they put their name on it.
- [Narrator] The film company
pivoted to commercial printing
and put its name on
tablets and smartphones.
In 2018, it introduced
its own cryptocurrency
called KodakCoin as part of a platform
to help photographers track
and license their work.
But over the last decade,
the company's stock price
has continued to decline,
then this happened.
- The coronavirus crisis.
- [Reporter] The coronavirus
death toll rising.
- And there are cases of the disease
here in the United States.
- [Narrator] In July amidst
concerns about availability
of American products
to help in the pandemic
President Donald Trump
announced Kodak had won
a first of its kind $765
million government loan
under the Defense Production Act.
- My administration has
reached a historic agreement
with a great American company.
You remember this company it's called
from the good old camera age,
the old days to begin producing critical
pharmaceutical ingredients,
it's called Kodak.
- Kodak was a chemical company.
They produced their own
processing chemicals
that went with photography, for a while
they own Sterling drug,
which is a chemical company.
So again, whether people
realize it or not,
it actually makes sense
for them to do that.
That's kind of what
their core business was.
- [Narrator] The company's
chief executive Jim Continenza
said he expected the loan to
create 300 jobs in Rochester
where Kodak's based and was
confident it would go through.
- Well, we feel very comfortable
that we can bank on it.
- [Narrator] But it soon
became clear to investors
that the deal was far from done.
A misworded alert about
the loan that Kodak
sent to local media before
the president's announcement
sent the company's stock
price on a rollercoaster ride.
The deal was put on pause as the SEC looks
at how Kodak disclosed the loan
and stock option grants to executives.
All this happens as the
company is losing money,
$5 million in the second quarter,
compared with a profit of
$201 million a year ago.
Kodak, a company whose products
helps capture era after era
is still trying to redefine
its own image in the current one.